this video was made possible by
curiosity stream when you sign up at the
link in the description you'll also get
access to nebula the streaming video
platform that Wendover is a part of a
quite reasonable question would be why
the American government is paying United
Airlines four million seven hundred and
eighty thousand nine hundred and fifty
five dollars a year to fly from their
hub in Newark to the small northern
Maine town of Presque Isle the question
could also be asked for why they pay
boutique air three million three hundred
and twenty eight thousand two hundred
and seven dollars a year to fly from
Dallas and Houston to the small Texan
city of Victoria or why United Airlines
has paid two million three hundred
seventeen thousand seventy three dollars
a year to fly from Denver to Pueblo
Colorado well these are subsidies and in
some cases quite hefty ones take that
flight from Houston to Victoria Texas
boutique will sell one of their seats on
their small prop plane for as low as
fifty four dollars on this route the
government however will chip in an
additional three hundred and eighty
dollars per passenger through this
subsidy for Denver to Pueblo Colorado
United sells tickets for eighty six
dollars more than pockets two hundred
and eighty two dollars from the
government
each of these routes and hundreds more
around the u.s. are part of a
little-known US government program
called
the essential air service the premise of
the program is simple for the most parts
and of course there are exceptions
flying to small towns is not profitable
for commercial airlines this makes sense
when operating an airline there are a
number of fixed costs for every flight
operated no matter if an aircraft seats
six passengers or six hundred an airline
is going to need to have check-in agents
baggage handlers and gate agents pilots
dispatchers sales agents and more since
those fixed costs are distributed
between fewer passengers with smaller
planes the cost operates per passenger
tends to get higher when you get down to
the smallest sizes of planes of course
airlines could compensate for this by
raising fares on these routes but like
many countries the US has a significant
economic divide between its rural and
urban parts in general the more
populated a place is the wealthier its
inhabitants are so say there's a city of
1 million and a town of 10,000 boring
any other variables you would expect the
demand for flights in the city of 1
million to be
about 100 times greater than in the town
of 10,000 since its population is 100
times greater but when you add the
real-world variable of income knowing
that those in the town of 10,000 earned
less demand would go down for flights
from the town since its inhabitants are
less able to pay therefore considering
income you might expect to have 150
times more demand from the city even
though its population is only 100 times
greater when you then add the variable
of price given that tickets average more
expensive from smaller towns that would
further reduce their demand so now a
city might have 200 times more demand
despite having only 100 times higher
population of course airlines need
demand to make a route file even if
they're only flying a tiny plane to that
10,000 person town daily they still need
seats filled to make it commercially
successful as we've just demonstrated
demand decreases exponentially these
smaller town gets to the number of small
towns that would actually prove to be
commercially viable to Airlines in the
US is small that's not to say they don't
exist though for example let's look at
Colorado's 13 commercial airports Grand
Junction Cortez Durango Telluride
Montrose Gunnison Aspen Hayden Eagle
County Alamosa webelo Colorado Springs
and Denver of these clearly Denver and
Colorado Springs as cities are not going
to be subsidized but then the remaining
11 airports are all in fairly small
towns however of these eleven only the
service to Cortez Alamosa and Pueblo are
subsidized with the essential air
service program now this is interesting
considering that Gunnison has a smaller
population than Cortez
Hayden has a smaller population than
Alamosa and Grand Junction has a smaller
population than pueblos the difference
between these three subsidized airports
and the other small ones is that these
are all in the mountains
Cortez Alamosa and Pueblo are not that
means that all these other airports are
near ski resorts and therefore have
strong inbound demand from tourists this
is the major circumstance when service
to small towns was commercially viable
alone when it serves tourist hotspots
but in other cases it's just extremely
rare for these types of routes to make
enough money for to be worth it to
Airlines so very simply the idea of the
essential air service program is
close the gap between what it takes for
a route to be worth it to an airline and
how much they'll earn from operating to
a small city through a bidding process
airlines will be grant to the contract
to operate these routes getting paid
anywhere from one hundred and forty four
thousand dollars a year as in the case
of mokulele Airlines is service from
Kailua Kona Hawaii up to four point
seven million dollars a year as in the
case of United Service from Newark to
Presque Isle Maine now airlines are paid
per flight operated not per passenger
which means that they will happily and
regularly operate flights with just a
couple or no passengers plenty of
airlines running EAS routes will be
profitable without selling a single
ticket solely through the government's
payment so a whole industry has arisen
around servicing these routes while the
large airlines like United Delta and
American do bid and operate these routes
the smallest plane they each operate is
a 50-seat crj200 plenty of these routes
have far less demand for than that even
if there's just one daily flight
that's why smaller airlines have evolved
take the example of air choice one there
a tiny airline operating a dozen Cessna
Grand caravans from Minneapolis to
Ironwood Mason City and Fort Dodge
Chicago to Ironwood Mason City and
Burlington Mason City the Fort Dodge in
Burlington st. Louis to Burlington Fort
Dodge Jonesboro and Jackson and then
finally Atlanta to Jackson of air toys
ones 13 routes every single one is
subsidized by the essential air service
the airline earns fifteen point seven
million dollars in revenue yearly
through this before actual ticket sales
these sorts of small regional airlines
of which there are dozens in the US
would likely not exist without the
essential air service program as the
type of flying they do would certainly
not be profitable worth mentioning is
that a system of subsidies for routes to
small towns is not unique to the u.s. in
Europe they're known as public service
obligation routes or PSO s this system
is a little more complicated than the
USA's with varying terms for when and
how airlines get paid but the amount of
compensation varies quite a bit more
than in the US for example in the UK the
effect of per passenger subsidy ranges
all the way from four dollars and 57
cents for fly B's route from London
Heathrow to nuki up to apparently more
than $1,000 per passenger in the case of
air Tasks routes in the Shetland Islands
the u.s. though has more
federally subsidized routes than the
entirety of the European Union because
after all the geography of the u.s. is
quite different the u.s. is one of the
least dense developed countries in the
world if the population of the u.s.
lived as densely as that of the UK it
would fit comfortably in just California
Nevada Utah and Arizona given this
spread it does have an issue with
transport the rural areas of the US are
just hard to get to and from and this
can make a bad economic situation worse
that's just one example companies can
and have made the decision to move their
operations whether factories are
headquarters from smaller towns to
bigger ones in order to be closer to
large airports outside the US transport
to rural areas is often provided by
train and while part of the reason for
the u.s. is minimal development of
passenger railroads is lack of interest
it would also be tough in many places to
build a financially viable passenger
railroad due to the country's vastness
without these flights the only public
transportation in or out of much of
rural America would be the bus at best
in the lower 48 this program helps
communities in Alaska though there are
plenty of communities that quite
literally would not exist without these
subsidies 65 of the USA's 179 EAS routes
are within the state of Alaska a big
reason for that is that only 14% of
Alaska's municipalities are connected to
the outside world by Road the state is
just so vast and harsh that building
roads to most of these areas wouldn't
make sense in place of roads Alaska's
rural towns have airports meaning that
in many cases they're essential air
service subsidized flights are the only
ways in or out so the way the essential
air service works is clear but is it
effective at its goal of elevating the
economy of rural areas of America well
according to one of the most
comprehensive studies done on the matter
in recent years every 1% increase in
passenger traffic at a subsidized
airport leads to the per capita income
of that community increasing by 0.12
percent it's tough to know exactly how
much of a passenger number increased the
program leads to but this at least
serves as evidence the underlying
supposition of the program that air
service leads to economic copper
Trinity is true what's also true though
is that the essential air service
program is not as efficient as it could
be for example for the longest time
southern Airways Express has been
getting 2.3 million dollars a year to
fly from Hagerstown Maryland to
Pittsburgh and Baltimore that's despite
the fact that BWI Airport is just 67
miles or 108 kilometers away from
Hagerstown in the air the flight takes
about 30 to 40 minutes given the slow
speed of the Cessna Grand Caravan
driving between the two airports takes
about 70 to 80 minutes and for anyone
without a car there are commercial
airport shuttles operating between
Hagerstown and BWI
what's more Hagerstown is also an hour's
drive from DC's national and Telus
airports and Hagerstown Airport even has
a regular non EAS subsidized routes to
Myrtle Beach Orlando and Tampa it's safe
to say that a town like Hagerstown is
benefitting far less from its
multi-million dollar subsidy than a town
like a DAC Alaska that's why in late
October 2019 hey Kirsten got the ax it
will no longer be subsidized by the
essential air service program under
increased scrutiny the requirements for
this program have gotten stricter and
stricter in recent years nowadays to be
eligible a community has to be more than
70 miles or 110 kilometres from the
nearest major airport has to cost the
government less than $200 per passenger
if it's within 210 miles or 340
kilometers of the nearest major airport
and has to average more than 10
passengers per day unless it's further
than 175 miles or 280 kilometers from
the nearest major airport with these
requirements more and more communities
are losing their funding some of these
are clearly justified
well flights might be nice nobody's
losing out on opportunity by having to
drive or take the bus an hour from
Hagerstown to BWI there is along has
been though talk of completely
eliminating the program now without
telling you what to think I'm just going
to present some numbers it cost the US
government about 290 million dollars a
year to run the essential air service a
program that connects hundreds of
communities to the outside world for
that same amount of money the government
could build about 40 miles or 65
kilometres of highway it could pay to
maintain all the US government's empty
or disused buildings for 62 days or it
could buy 1/7 of a
two spirit bomber in government terms
290 million dollars just isn't
that's much some exciting news I've just
gotten back from filming a documentary
about something somewhere that's all the
info you get aside from that it's
actually good and then it's a nebula
original meaning that to watch it when
it comes out at the end of November
you'll have to head to nebula the
streaming site built by myself and a
bunch of other creators to make that
easier though nebula has partnered with
curiosity stream the streaming site home
to thousands of top quality
documentaries and nonfiction TV shows
curiosity stream is worth signing up for
by itself beyond just its great library
it's available pretty much everywhere
for a very reasonable cost of just three
dollars a month that three dollars a
month curiosity stream membership though
now also gets you access to nebula if
you sign up at curiosity string comm
slash went over that's really an amazing
deal for to top quality streaming sites
and the best part is you'll be
supporting myself and so many other
independent creators while you do it